today on the matt welsh show some leaked
audio from a queer inclusive
presentation at a major education
conference reveals exactly what our kids
are being subjected to at school both
public and private schools by the way
also some college students are now
protesting to demand that mask mandates
remain in place but why do they need a
mandate can't they just wear their masks
if they want to and a major racism
scandal at a school in illinois but i
have some questions about it plus blm
bails out the activists who tried to
assassinate a mayoral candidate in
louisville and in our daily cancellation
disney is now branching out beyond
movies and shows and theme parks and now
we'll be running entire towns
communities where you can go and live
every day of your life
in disney's dystopia but why in god's
name would anybody want to do that we'll
talk about that and much more today on
the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
did you know that 85 percent of the
grass-fed beef in the united states is
imported from overseas not only that but
did you know that these foreign products
are often labeled product of usa since
they're minimally processed here in the
usa good news is you don't need to
settle for low quality foreign meat
because of our friends over at good
ranchers good rancher sells 100 american
meat and delivers it to your door for a
great price their beef is prime and
upper choice the highest quality
possible they've got rib eyes t-bones
new york strips and more plus their
packaging makes it easy to cook
what you want and then you can save the
rest which keeps keeps you from from
wasting anything although the challenge
is can you hold on to the good ranch or
meat for uh longer than a week i haven't
been able to do that because you want to
eat it all as soon as you can but head
on over to goodranchers.com walsh today
to solve your meat problem once and for
all get the transparency quality and
cuts you've been craving order now with
code walsh to get 30 off your box now's
the time to support american farms and
ranches they're they're hurting and also
you're hungry so you can solve both of
those problems two birds one stone with
a box of american meat delivered whoever
buys the meat in your house needs to go
to goodranchers.com
walsh today
you know it's no secret that i'm not a
very big fan of public school you may
have heard me mention that a time or two
i don't know
uh but it's important to remember that
the problems with the public school
system are only partially caused by the
fact that the government runs the
institution i mean sure our government
is an incompetent inefficient meandering
morally bankrupt behemoth monstrosity
and tossing your children into its mouth
is a bit like uh what was it jabba the
hutt feeding prisoners into the the
sarlacc i think it was called you don't
get star wars references from me very
often so please appreciate them when
they come but many parents make the
mistake of thinking that all of the
education systems almost literal
pitfalls can be avoided just by avoiding
the great chunk of that system which is
run by the state and so they simply
shuffle their children off to private
school and believe that the problem has
been solved
unfortunately it's rarely that simple
because the other great problem with
public school aside from those issues
that can be linked directly to the
government
is that it is a product of the culture
and the culture is also a product of it
so it's one big circle a snake eating
its tail but this often applies to
private school just as much as public
moreover in both cases whether private
or public your child's mental and moral
formation is being outsourced to
strangers to adults you don't know
now it's possible to find private
schools that are not that are not
products of the greater culture and
which are run and staffed by adults that
you can actually trust to handle the
precious task of educating your kids
but the preponderance of private schools
do not fall into that category
and this report from breitbart i think
shows that pretty well so here's the
report published yesterday it says
private schools across the country are
training teachers to expose kids as
young as four years old to sexually
explicit content in secrecy and without
parents knowledge directed by the
national association of independent
schools nais as part of a queer
inclusive curriculum breitbart news has
reviewed an extensive trove of nin nais
documents and teacher training supplied
to private schools nationwide which
under the guise of being queer and lgbtq
plus inclusive
urged the use of graphic sexual material
in classes starting at pre-k
so breitbart apparently got its hands on
uh
mainly this training workshop
presentation at a major nais conference
in philadelphia a year or two ago it's
an hour long and speakers instruct the
assembled on how to talk to kids as
young as four years old about sex and
gender identity so we'll go through this
here's one clip from an unnamed
presenter
explaining what kids in pre-k should be
told
with the younger children starting in
pre-k
we talk about their bodies about the
parts that they were born with
about penises and vaginas and whether
that makes somebody a boy or a girl
but also their feelings
what do they feel like inside do they
feel like a boy or a girl what does
their head say does their head and their
heart and their body match up
now to emphasize again this is pre-k
typical age for pre-k is four years old
kids at four have only been speaking in
complete sentences for you know a year
and a half or two years
most of them probably have been potty
trained for a year at most maybe less
still can't tie their shoes
and already they're being introduced to
gender ideology at a time when they
could not possibly be expected to notice
how incoherent it is
because a four-year-old isn't going to
raise his hand and say yes mrs smith the
claim that a person can be a male
physically and yet a female in some
ambiguous spiritual sense strikes me as
the strangest and most schizophrenic
form of mind-body dualism and is at best
a religious conviction which has no
place in a curriculum ostensibly based
in science
now even the smartest four-year-old
isn't going to say that they're just
going to sit and nod their heads or
stare blankly as the seeds of insanity
are planted in their helpless minds
now in another clip a different
presenter laughs about a time when she
accidentally quote unquote showed
graphic images to a room full of young
children listen
there are missteps where we have to take
a step back and refine i'm going to
share one of my missteps
when i started my first year teaching
with the health and wellness team i had
been given a title to a book so i went
to our school library to pull it
and i pulled it thinking i had the right
one i didn't
um and i read through i'm like this is
really progressive stuff but it was my
first year so i'm like okay we're just
super progressive so i went in there
guns blazing and i just went for it and
i ended up talking about the vulva and
the labia with pre-cares and it was just
one of those moments everybody's looking
in [ __ ] and i'm like oh no i made a
really big mistake
and i share that with you because it's
not perfect right it's a practice so be
kind to yourselves when you're like
delving into this
yes be kind to yourselves as groomers
and predators just a bit of a silly
slapstick comedy there she exposed young
children to sexual content that even she
knew was inappropriate isn't that
hilarious
maybe she could tell that story at the
next pedophiles anonymous meeting and
get a good laugh
now the children she says are like
sexual lab rats basically you can try
different things it's a practice
trial and error type of thing
notice something the parents are not
mentioned
at any point in any of these clips
there is not even lip service paid to
the idea that the parents should have a
say in whether their kids are exposed to
this content
they're not even worried about it it
doesn't come up
moving to another clip we're now told
what the second grade lesson plan is
like now we we have we have dived into
radical gender theory in pre-k so then
what's happening once we get a few years
down the line let's listen
by second grade we move on explicitly to
gender identity and talk about it again
in terms of your head and your heart and
your body parts matching up and does
that work for you
what happens if it doesn't what are the
other parts of you that have to do with
your gender identity and what are the
parts of you that don't and the kids
draw wonderful self-portraits again um
but dealing with all aspects of their
identity including specifically their
gender
okay so that's second grade now before
we talk about that i want to play one
more clip for you
because we go through you know pre-k
kindergarten first grade second grade
then they go third fourth fifth and we
get up to fifth grade
and uh and listen to what's happening by
the time we get to fifth grade and
beyond starting in fifth grade we start
using the words for that that sex
is
what you were born with
it's external and internal genitalia
it's hormones and chromosomes
that's
something that you can only change with
a whole lot of effort
gender identity is how you feel inside
it's what you feel like in your heart
and in your head just like the language
that we used when they were younger but
it's something personal it's something
that's unique to you it's something that
you get to decide gender expression is
what you share with the world
how you dress how you act what you're
interested in what you put out there and
that again is your choice it's something
that you can change from day to day it's
completely up to you sexual orientation
is who you are emotionally and
physically attracted to and so
that's how we talk about it with the
kids and introduce them to it fifth
grade is our big year it's um
not that all of them aren't
but we do the reproductive system
and puberty
um
the we
talk about gender identity specifically
with the gender unicorn this time
talking about things as a continuum
um
for gender identity and expression sex
assigned at birth who you're physically
attracted to and who you're emotionally
attracted to so all those aspects of
gender identity and sexuality and we do
read a book it the kids are like you're
reading us a story book we're in fifth
grade um but it does a lovely job of
talking about gender identity
the gender unicorn
now they've been using this thing for
years and it hasn't gotten any more
sophisticated or coherent over time on
the gender unicorn chart the kids are
told that there are five spectrums not
just one
gender identity gender expression sex
you're which is also a spectrum now um
your physical attraction and your
emotional attraction so we're drawing a
distinction there and these are all
supposed to be distinct and lucid
categories on their own of course in
reality in practice they're not
these become at best different vaguely
defined pockets of confusion none of
this helps the kids better understand
themselves
no kid is looking at the gender unicorn
chart and say oh i unders okay i get it
now
it has exactly the opposite effect which
is intended
all of this is about deconstructing the
child's identity unpersoning them taking
away everything that's solid and real
and true and distinct and unique
infecting them with a lifelong identity
crisis
but notice something else
we've heard the uh the quote-unquote
queer curriculum
from pre-k all the way to fifth grade
now the lessons and the language don't
really change at all during that time
it's not as though the kids are
introduced to the concept of gender
identity and then are taken deeper into
it introduced to increasingly complex
aspects of it the way that we do with a
subject like writing or
you know mathematics
now instead it's repetition like a
religious creed
the same basic concept repeated over and
over and over and over again
and as they get into college and alleged
adulthood
it doesn't change
you can enroll in a gender studies
program in an ivy league school
and you'll be hearing the same slogan
sex is your body and your gender
identity is how you feel inside
it's literally the same thing that they
tell preschoolers
at no point at any age at any level is
is this idea actually explained in a way
that makes sense
because it doesn't make sense
instead the slogan is is related over
and over and over again
and that's because all of this stuff is
vapid and shallow
and goes no deeper than a puddle of piss
on the bathroom floor
and that's why they want to get to the
kids as early as possible so that they
can be fully invested in it fully
inducted into the cult
before they're old enough to ask even
the most basic questions
because none of this can withstand even
the most basic questions
and of course underlying all of this
and all these efforts
is this immense inordinate sense of
entitlement
by the education system generally and
especially among the queer activists
within it
they believe that they're owed your
children's hearts minds and souls
that's a ransom that you're supposed to
pay them they believe
it's what they're entitled to
hand your children over they say and let
the groomers do as they wish
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
so we're in a
a different studio right now an off-site
location our normal studios are out of
commission for a few days
and we were here yesterday and
they put this super fake looking picture
of our old studio on a screen behind me
which is actually a picture of a picture
because even at our normal studio it's
just a picture on a screen while the new
studios are being built
so this is a this is the the screen
capture of a picture of what once
existed but no longer does
a lot of studio upheaval going on in my
life right now but i texted sean my
producer last night and i said you know
we can't do the fake screen again
because i was looking at some of the
comments and we're not we're not fooling
anybody we can't fool the sweet baby
gang they we're not going to get one
over on them
maybe knowles fans
they didn't know
they can be suckered because they're not
even a gang they aren't sweet babies at
all
um but but not the sbg so let's just be
honest we're just we're in a different
studio no reason to try to fake it but i
was told this is the only option we have
to go with this so this is what we're
stuck with it looks like a high school
green screen it looks like um you know
it looks like i'm doing the morning
announcements
in high school in 2005.
otherwise the setup is fine the only
only other problem being here is that
everybody's in the room with me
currently while i'm talking to you
um just sort of sitting off in the dark
lurking staring at me which is odd
and you have to understand something
like because you know usually if i'm at
regular studio they're in the control
room i know they're listening but
they're not actually in the room with me
you have to understand i you know i
started
this journey in my car totally by myself
and the only physical audience was just
a guy walking his dog and peering in the
window like what the hell is going on in
there
and even back then the only actual
audience even online was also just one
guy
clicking on it going what the hell's
going on in there
so it's just that it's a different sort
of experience that's kind of awkward but
we'll be fine
um you know i'm guessing not many of you
are part of any book clubs while the
third thursday book club with ben
shapiro might just change that because
it's not your average book club first of
all ben is not going to be discussing
tawdry poorly written romance novels
written by stacey abrams
unfortunately i think i'd probably
joined the book club myself if
we were talking about a stacey abrams
romance novel but he's going to help you
experience the greatest books ever
written and you're going to be doing
that together live we're talking books
like 1984 by george orwell huckleberry
finn by mark twain and many more these
are the works that shaped western art
and culture and ben is going to show you
why and why this book uh these books
still matter today third thursday book
club allows you to engage with ben like
never before he's going to answer your
questions you're talking about the book
it's a lot of fun by the way you're
going to love the immersive sets wait
till you see what they created for huck
finn i mean it's an immersive set much
like the one that i'm sitting
on right now ben shapiro is gathering
everyone tonight at 8 p.m eastern 7 p.m
central haven't heard huckleberry thin
finn well join the third thursday book
club anyway i promise you'll feel well
read by the time it's done because ben
is going to be your guide and he's going
to show you why huckleberry finn is such
an important work of american fiction
when you sign up you'll also get
personal um notes from ben which is a
cheat sheet to the important lessons
themes and characters so this is this
actually a good strategy you don't have
to read the books at all
but you join the book club you get the
cheat sheet from ben and you listen to
him talk about it and then you can
always then it counts as reading it and
you can always claim that you read it
and if anyone says i don't believe that
you read it then just plagiarize
whatever points been made about the book
and they'll believe you and remember
you're doing all this with thousands of
daily wire members live this is not like
any book club you've ever been a part of
so remember sign up for the third
thursday book club at third
thursdaybookclub.com
tonight at 8 p.m eastern 7 pm central
so students at the university of nevada
reno
were protesting yesterday
because because they aren't being
required to wear a mask
they're protesting the lack of a rule
which is
kind of a kind of a new idea especially
for college students
how often do you see college students
protesting because there aren't enough
rules put in place governing governing
their behavior
times have really changed and so that's
what they're protesting but it raises
all kinds of questions and which we will
ask but first let's watch the local news
report about this protest
some unr students trying to get
university administrators to hear them
they want the mask mandate to be
reinstated ben marjot reports from
campus on why some say it's too soon to
ditch the masks
[Music]
four days after governor steve sisilak's
mask mandate ended
some on campus want it back coming on
the heels of dropping our vaccine
mandate so we really have nothing
official in place protecting students
right now 50 or so students and some
faculty walking out monday to protest
the governor's decision saying it was
based in politics not science i just
feel sort of offended and annoyed that
he's placing his own political career
above everybody's safety after marching
to the quad the group heard from several
people who explained their reasoning for
continuing to mask up even when they
don't have to i am in gonna compromise
okay i have asthma we need you know the
entire everybody to be vaccinated or if
it does not in that case at least we
should be at a mass last week unr
president brian sandoval said he doesn't
have the power to impose tighter
restrictions on his own but chemistry
professor ken irvin disagrees well in
the chemistry labs we require that
students wear lab coats and that they
have full toed shoes
those are for the safety of the
students and it's not based on a state
mandate or a federal mandate
yeah that's in it that's in a science
lab okay but then that's not the entire
world that's not everyday life well in a
in a lab we have to wear lab coats and
yeah on a construction site they have to
wear hard hats
that's a good question why don't why
don't why don't we require people to
wear hard hats everywhere they go why
don't we you know bicycle helmets at
least
but really really full motorcycle
helmets with the visor and everything i
think that would solve a lot of problems
maybe we'll require the full full
motorcycle helmet put a mandate in place
and then that's going to protect against
covet at least as well as the as the
dumb masks do
and
um
and also it protects against other you
know things falling out of the sky
falling coconuts you could trip and fall
people people die from falls all the
time
trip down the steps
why not require that
but of course the big question again is
all all of these kids are upset that
there's not a mandate in place that
there's not a rule they want more rules
governing their lives
you know it used to be that youth was a
was a time for rebellion
rebellion against the rules
right yeah i can remember uh
i'm an old man now but back in my youth
there was
you had this like instinct even to
to break rules just for the sake of
breaking them i mean you wanted to break
rules that were there were even good
rules that were put in place for your
actually put in place for your own
health and safety and that you should
listen to but there was still this this
compulsion you know some sometimes
overwhelming to to break it to try to
break through free from these uh
from
these constrictions
and now we've got young people that are
far on the other end of the spectrum
that their form of youthful rebellion is
demanding more rules governing their
lives
forcing them to wear something
but the big question is okay if you want
to wear the mask
just wear it
and if you have faith
in the mask's ability to protect you
then it shouldn't matter that must you
whether other people are wearing them
i mean we're supposed to believe that
these people i mean every one of that
protest we can assume is i mean they're
certainly vaccinated they're triple
vaxxed we know i think we can assume
that right so
every single person that protests triple
backs
most of them double mask so they're
triple vacs double masked
and yet they still
feel like they're being persecuted if
other people aren't required to wear
masks
and yet we're supposed to believe that
that they that they think that the masks
and the vaccines are effective
they certainly they certainly aren't
acting like it
now on the same note here with covid um
up in canada the ontario premiere
um
says that he uh
more and more politicians in canada are
coming out against the tyrant justin
trudeau
relative both in spirit and genetically
i think of fidel castro more and more
people are coming out against him and
here's the um
the premiere of of uh
of ontario saying that he's well he's
done with covet i want to play this clip
and this is something that we've we've
heard a lot this is a this is a mantra
that we've we've heard over the last
couple of weeks a couple months
um from liberals from people who used to
be fully invested in the cove and panic
now they're saying i'm done with it i'm
done with it um and here's the latest
listen to this
you know you can go to you can go to
costco you can go to walmart you go
shopping
you know you don't know if the person
has a shop beside you or not but we also
know that it doesn't matter if you have
one shot or 10 shots you can catch covet
see the prime minister has triple shots
and i i know hundreds of people three
shots that caught covet we just have to
be careful we gotta always make sure we
wash our hands and and move forward but
colin we can't stay in this position
forever we've got to learn to live with
this and get on with our lives i bet if
i ask every single person
in this room you want these damn masks
or do you want them off they want them
off
they want to get back to normal they
want to be able to go for dinner with
their families and there's every single
person including myself and those people
that are unvaccinated
you know sure there's there's a rebel
rousers
and then there's just hard-working
people that just don't believe in it and
that's their choice
this is about again a democracy and
freedoms and liberties and
i hate as a government telling anyone
what to do we just got to get moving
forward and get out of this and protect
the jobs
you know
i think a lot of people call them
probably yourself too everyone's done
with us like we are done with it
let's let's start moving on and
cautiously and
you know we we've followed the rules all
of us not like 90 of us for for over two
years the world's done with it so let's
just move forward
okay i agree with everything you just
said there obviously um and i've been
saying that a lot of us have been saying
that this entire time um
and we were shouted down for two years
and now we've got people like him and
many politicians people on the left as
well who are
repeating the things that we said for
two years and a lot of times these are
the people who can the same exact people
who condemned us
up until five seconds ago and now
they're now they're joining
in this uh
joining us in in uh in the realm of
sanity which i appreciate i would i
would love some acknowledgement i mean i
would love an apology it's not going to
come i would love and it's not an
apology just some acknowledgement
from from from one of these people
you know when they when they when we
hear yet another one come out and say
i'm done with covet i would love for one
of them to say you know what i was wrong
about this
the entire time i was wrong about this
and the other side was right and i would
love to hear that acknowledge but it's
never going to happen
and that's why i'm a little bit annoyed
with the well we're we're done with
coveted line
because what you're telling me is that
you you put up with this tyranny
that i guess you you always knew was
irrational and made no sense and you you
put up with it and now you just don't
feel like putting up with it anymore and
you've reached the limits of your own
patience and now you're personally done
with it so let's all just i'm done with
that let's all just move on to the next
thing
now you you were able to tolerate it for
a year and a half to two years
and now you're done with it so the world
can move on
there's there's something about that
that i find something about that logic
that i find very frustrating i would i
would much rather hear from these folks
that you know what i was duped by this
i believed what i was told
i thought that the lockdowns and the
masking and everything and all the
mandates i i thought that would solve
the problem i thought by now we'd be
living in a covert free world
and uh and i and i have only just
realized because i'm a very stupid
person i've only just realized that
that's not the case and that we're gonna
have to live with this it's always going
to be with us and so we should have just
lived with it from the beginning i would
prefer to hear that
but instead what i hear well i'm just
done with it now i'm bored with it let's
do something else
i find that to be pretty frustrating
this is also frustrating from whas in
louisville uh local news reporter says a
louisville bail fund organization is
planning to pay the bond for a man
charged with the attempted murder
of a mayoral candidate
chanel helm an organizer for black lives
matter louisville
said wednesday that the louisville
community bail fund is planning to pay
the 100 000 bond set for quintes brown
uh and this report was yesterday i think
as of now they've actually they actually
have gone and bailed them out um
helms said the organization has enough
money to bail brown out of metro
corrections where he's been held since
his arrest on february 14th she said
they are
he's been held since february 14th which
was
uh like a day and a half before they
bailed him out all the way back on
february 14th she said they're hoping to
um have him out of jail by wednesday but
the process is still being finalized
helms said she wants to have a plan in
place so brown will have access to the
mental health resources he needs when he
gets out
by the way his bond i don't know if this
is okay hundred thousand dollars was the
uh was the bond
for a an attempted political
assassination an attempted assassin he
walked in to this guy's office and tried
to shoot him
at essentially point blank range
and the victim is saved by the fact that
quintes brown
aside from being a murdering scumbag is
also a terrible shot and that that's the
only thing that saved him
so you could walk in to a politician's
office and try to kill him
and be out of jail in a few days on a
hundred thousand dollars bond
well no
you can't do that i mean it really
depends doesn't it
because as much as we're told about
white privilege in the system
um
the most outrageous cases that i can
think in recent memory of people being
bailed out of jail after committing
horrific crimes those are not white
people
because there's this case and then
there's also the one down in in florida
the school shooter who shot multi
multiple people in school
and was out of jail in a couple of days
going home to a to a welcome home party
they posted the pictures on social media
and that guy gets to just hang out
until his trial
same for this guy and whenever his trial
comes i'm sure i'm sure we're going to
hear a lot about in fact the media is
already reporting about how
you know he's an activist and a social
justice leader and but he's a very very
troubled guy and he's
had some heart ran into some hard times
in his life and
so he just made a mistake and he when he
went and tried to went in someone's
office and tried to kill him it's just a
simple but we all make mistakes this was
a youthful indiscretion
that's already the narrative from the
media
is this uh what kind of privilege is
this it's not white privilege
and blm they they're not hiding and they
never really have they've always been
pretty explicit about what the
organization's all about
so you you if you haven't paid much
attention to blm you might think that
given the fact that this guy was a noted
prominent blm activist who had been
hailed and celebrated by everyone up up
to
barack obama and his foundation had been
on msnbc and all of that had been
writing you know articles for
mainstream publications you would think
that blm would try to distance
themselves if you didn't know any better
you would think that blm would try to
distance themselves and say oh you know
this guy really had nothing to do with
us he was not you know he went to a
couple of events but he wasn't official
you think that would be
their approach if you didn't know any
better but not at all
they got money together marched down
there and got them out of jail
you know what they also haven't done as
far as i know um they haven't put out
any statement
condemning this
or anything
and that's because they don't condemn it
and they don't even pretend to
they are
the
the most violent domestic terrorist
organization in the country and they
they don't even really hide it
they
rely on the media to hide it for them
meanwhile on their own website if you go
and this might this may be one actually
they've taken some of this down now so
they are hiding it a little bit they're
making a few attempts to cover some some
of their tracks but
for years you go to their website
and look at their mission statement
they're pretty explicit that their goal
is to destroy western civilization
and the nuclear family
but you know you don't need to hide it
when you've got the media in your back
pocket
um so speaking of racism a racism
controversy at a school in illinois
that's
you know making some waves online but i
have some questions about this i'm a
little bit confused let's let's watch
the local news report about this
tonight we'll hear from school leaders
about an incident involving so-called
white privilege cards and local groups
say the school handled the situation
well news 3's danny valliere is in
jackson county with more
intolerance is not acceptable and it's
not okay at our school and it's not
something that would be tolerated these
white privilege cards are actually gags
you can buy off amazon but a local civil
rights group says jokes about racism are
no laughing matter it's telling the
children that if they have a certain
type of skin color
that they don't have privilege that they
can't do whatever they want to do last
week a sixth grade boy at unity point
school received one of the cards
according to chastity mays of the race
unity group of carbondale it made him
feel really bad he really didn't kind of
understand what was happening dean of
students mary beth goff says the school
acted quickly holding a conference with
the families involved and making time
for conversations about race with small
groups of students from fifth through
eighth grade i think our goal really is
to look at the safety of our students
and we want to make sure bottom line
that our kids are safe here at school
and that they feel safe goff says the
conversations are an important teachable
moment for students and for teachers who
occasionally have to think outside their
lesson plan you take that opportunity
and you use that to teach the students
not just about this one incident but
really about the role that hate has
played throughout time
in our world
and unfortunately still placed today and
mays couldn't agree more if the children
of color are old enough to experience
racism
all the children in the school are old
enough to address the subject goff could
not provide specifics on the students
involved in this incident she does say
so first of all i love how she she
actually
literally said
uh intolerance won't be tolerated so
intolerance won't be tolerated except
for uh the intolerance of
intolerance we're gonna tolerate that
intolerance but all other forms of
intolerance will not be tolerated
um the thing that that that confuses me
though is that this was uh so it's a
white privilege card and it's like a
little credit card that they didn't the
one thing they didn't tell you is okay
the kid who got this car like who where
to get it and
was the k the kid who was handed the
card was he a white kid or a black kid
uh
so i i assume it was a white kid and and
who and who in that was it a white black
kid who handed it to him
these these questions are not answered
which makes me very much suspect that it
was a black child handing the white
privilege card to a white child
why would that happen well because the
white privilege card it's like a little
credit card and it says white privilege
and then it's you know it says it
says that you're you get off scot-free
and you have this this card you can cash
in any time because you're white
and it makes your life so easy
okay so what i'm trying to figure out is
how are the black kids the victim of
that
is it
the whole point is it's an attack on the
kid who was given the card it's accusing
it's it's not it's do they think it's
literally a card which actually gives
privilege
that that
this person was handed this credit card
or they can actually go to like target
or something and use it to buy whatever
they want
no the card is supposed to be making a
point and the point it's it's trying to
make is that white people have privilege
and their lives are super easy
and uh they're all a bunch of entitled
selfish brats right that's the idea
behind the white privilege claim
and yet this is an attack on the black
kids
so are are we now being told is this
what we're being told
that white that the concept of white
privilege
is racist
against black people
and we heard from one of the teachers
there she said well when you say that a
white kid has privilege then you're
you're claiming that black that black
children don't have privileges
right yeah i
yeah and i agree with you that that's
wrong that we shouldn't be saying that
that we shouldn't be telling people
based on their skin color that they do
or don't have certain privileges but
that's what we've been saying the whole
time
again just like with covet this is what
we've been saying that white privilege
is a racist concept to go around telling
people that they have privilege based on
race is racist
but it's racist against the white people
but if if this is if this is the end
result is that now we can't talk about
white privilege anymore because somehow
they found a way to make the black kids
the victims of it then fine
i'll take it
if it means we can stop talking about
white privilege
um
here's a privilege that nobody has
whether you're white or black or any
color uh and that is to leave your
shopping carts in the parking lot
without putting them into their
appropriate receptacles which are laid
out at every parking lot
and uh there's a an account on twitter
and youtube a great account called
carton arcs and what they do people send
me their videos all the time
assuming that i'm somehow involved you
know in some kind of capacity with this
organization i would i would love to be
involved but i'm actually not this is
something they're doing on their own
and uh and they are they are in fact
heroes i think they're you know
one of the great heroes of
western civilization right now still
living and what they do is they go out
um across the country and they film and
chain people who leave their shopping
carts in parking lots
and i i always watch these videos and
sometimes they get a good reaction out
of somebody i don't think they've ever
got a reaction like this though so this
is outside of a i think it's outside of
a costco
and let's go ahead and
just start playing this video this is
good stuff
oh look at that
a half curving word that's not where the
cards go sir
well you should because they want shut
your mouth punk what does the sign say
on the cart return
please return carts here yeah and the
card's right there it doesn't say please
return cards there you're gonna put
maggie to shame sir
now sir
well as soon as you return your card
flag he's putting a flag on the car
would you like a magnet instead flag
shaming him for now sir
as soon as you take your card
you guys wearing a mask you already
guessed that
look at yourself
who's perry carabella live
look sir
sir there's a guy in a mask threatening
to eat another person but he cares about
safety
he cares about the safety of his
fellow
man this guy is so angry he's getting
double magnets
and the flag
watch out behind you sir
all right
what a jerk face this actually goes on
for like another two minutes
uh look what this guy did first of all
look at the move that this guy tried to
pull when he's ditching the the shopping
cart
he edges the shopping cart up on to the
grass and then kind of leaves it there
and assumes that that's good enough
and i'm and i'm quite glad that the
carton arks they're not taking any of
that that's not that is not good enough
that's not that isn't yeah okay it's a
little bit better than just leaving it
in the middle of the parking lot where a
gust of wind can take it and like a
battering ram slam it into someone you
know someone's uh someone else's car uh
so at least you've anchored it but
that's not where the carts go and if you
have the time
to put it and edge it up on the grass or
up on a median strip or something then
you could just take it back and and here
we can see he's like maybe eight or nine
spaces away from the front of the store
he could just bring it right back to the
front of the store and also this guy
with his um fedora and his face mask on
he's by himself
okay he's by himself he's also a little
bit overweight he could use the exercise
and just go take it's a beautiful day
outside
blue skies mild temperatures just go
take a nice stroll down to the front of
the front of the uh the store and leave
your shopping cart there
and you benefit from it you get some
fresh air you get some exercise you
definitely need it
and you're doing the right thing for
society you can feel better about
yourself
but this guy cannot be bothered to even
do that for his fellow man
even walking 20 feet he cannot be
bothered to do it
which tells you if you if you can't do
the right thing in these small little
moments when it costs you nothing then i
can guarantee
you're not gonna do the right thing when
it caught when it actually does cost you
something
so i'm glad we have the carton arcs out
there doing the right thing shaming
these people
and um
well done sirs
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
all right dailywire.com sweet baby
comments if you want to leave a video
comment let's start with uh clip 10. hi
matt walsh
i'm sorry did you say that you don't
know how to change a diaper
you have four children
and you don't know how to change a
diaper
i really really hope that was a joke
you kind of mumbled it kind of seemed
ashamed of it so
thinking it might not be a joke
please tell me it was a joke
if it wasn't
you really need to consider canceling
yourself
sweet baby gang for life
oh don't don't attack me don't attack me
on such a
don't
uh
come to me with this ableist
attack and then say sweet baby gang for
life don't don't do that yeah i don't
know how to to change a diaper i don't
my wife i've been telling my wife this
for ten years
or eight years however long we've had
kids i don't even remember i i don't
know how to do it it's how do you it's
too complicated especially
uh when when there's you know when it's
a p diaper i can i can kind of figure it
out but when it's a big nasty poop
diaper and it smells and stinking up the
whole house i i don't know how to do it
i can't do i'd love to do it i just
can't and the other thing is a lot of
times i forget like if i'm if i'm
watching the kids and and uh a kid poops
in a diaper and my wife is out of the
house
um i'll a lot of times the other thing
is it's a mental thing we're all i'll
sort of forget that
the diaper needs to be changed
until my wife gets home and then i'll
remember and i'll say oh by the way as
soon as she walks in the door i'll say
oh by the way we got to change that
diaper
and i'll remember but that's not my
fault
and i have a medical condition too you
know i have i have a very i have a
strong i have a
stronger than average sense of smell and
so it it really upsets me physically and
emotionally to change diapers i got a
lot of excuses
it's not my fault
but the result is
that over
uh
eight years
you know i've probably changed two
diapers
you could judge me for that
or you could admire me
i think a lot of the men in the audience
you should admire my skills
at evading that responsibility
it's not easy to do
all right let's uh go to this says bmac
says hey matt you were talking about
protecting our kids as a society and i
wanted to bring up a situation that's
been weighing heavy on my mind i
recently flew on delta and i was shocked
when i found out that delta allows um
sorry i'm just thinking about all the
extremely angry messages i'm going to
have coming my way because of what i
just said about i've changed more than
two i mean i you know that's
i've probably changed at least seven
years
eight years i've probably changed at
least
at least 20.
so let me be fair to myself anyway
i recently flew on delta and i was
shocked when i found out that delta
allows r-rated shows with sexual content
on their uh tvs on the back of the seats
it's almost impossible to not see what
those are watching around you and i was
thinking about all the children that
would be exposed to seeing the violent
sexually explicit scenes from some of
the shows i'm so frustrated at a loss of
what to do
if kids can't get into an r-rated movie
in theaters until they're 17 why can
they be exposed to it on a delta flight
i have left a complaint with delta but
not sure we'll do anything i'd love to
hear your thoughts on this matter if you
have time
thank you well i i totally agree with
you and have the same exact thought
every time i'm flying and they've got
the the tvs on the back of the seats um
and there have been plenty of times when
uh you know i'm scrolling through
looking for something to watch
and you see some you know violent action
movie or whatever and it's rated r
and i think well yeah if i was if i was
at home
in my living room i'd probably put this
one on but this is like we're totally
exposed out here they're kids around and
not it's not appropriate content for
everybody to see
um
but i think most people they don't even
think about that
anymore and i notice this all the time
also on planes people put on not just
violent movies but they put on sexually
explicit movies with you know nude
scenes and everything that are still
allowed on these flights
and uh it people without any shame are
just watching it but other you know got
flight attendants walking by they're
sitting you're sitting right next to two
other people
their kids
i think people are so conditioned to
simply not think about
anyone else but themselves and
especially when it comes to
entertainment
we are conditioned to believe
that whatever we want to do for our own
entertainment we have a right to do it
and and it's absurd for anyone to
criticize us
and uh
and or to judge us for it i think that's
how we're kind of conditioned
um
kaziah says if matt can pronounce my
name correctly then i'm going to make my
husband buy and wear a sweet daddy walsh
t-shirt
kazaya
did i do it right k-e-z-i-a-h
and then s so yeah cause i
i went through all the options one of
them has to be right
and the end result is that you have to
go and buy a sweet daddy
uh sweet baby gang shirt we actually
don't have a sweet daddy walsh t-shirt
and i do draw the line there we can't
sell that that's one thing we cannot
sell
um john l says matt do you think that
gen z is more screwed up by the internet
because of being exposed to it so young
or less screwed up because it's been a
normal part of their life
lots of boomers i know seem to have gone
insane because of social media maybe
there's something to be said for early
exposure
uh
i i think i understand what you're what
you're getting at but without a doubt
there's no question that gen z is more
screwed up by the internet more screwed
up in in general but especially by the
internet because they're exposed to it
so young
you know i think
my generation as screwed up as we are
on balance we are less so especially by
the internet
because
the big big part of the reason here is
that is that people who are my age
we can remember
first of all we had some kind of life
before the internet so we know what that
was like
and we had at least the first part of
our childhood in an internet free world
and uh in a world where you had there
was nothing else to do right but i mean
you could watch tv and sit around play
video games but um it it had not taken
over life in the same way that it does
now the screens had not completely
consumed everyone's lives and so it's
still very common back when i was eight
years old to you know you look outside
your window and all the kids in the
neighborhood are playing outside um
and so we we had that experience at
least for the first part of our
childhood
which kids these days
you know a kid who was born
a kid in general in gen z or my kids
generation um
they they never lived in a world
where this stuff didn't exist and also
you know we can remember
encountering this thing
right i people talk all the time about
oh do you remember where you were when 9
11 happened do you remember where you
were when this or that thing happened
and i i can remember where i was when i
first
encountered the internet for the first
time i was at my friend's house i think
i was in third grade and i'd never he
had a computer i knew what computers
were we didn't have one um they were
still not very common computers at least
as household items i'd never even heard
of the internet and i was at my friend's
house and he told me about and i went on
and he was it was like aol 1.0 at the
time and the internet was a much smaller
place back then so there are a couple
little boxes you could click and it
would take you to oh here's the section
for news here's the section for
entertainment here's a section for games
and i kind of scrolled around it for
about five minutes and i thought this is
really boring and uh that was it the
last so it's the last time i thought
about it for several years so i can i
can remember encountering it at least
which means that
i always am going to see it as something
sort of
outside something foreign something that
was that's an addition to my life
even if it's even if it tends to
overtake all of our lives even as older
people
but for gen z they
they just grew up in a world that was
completely defined by the internet i
don't even think they see the internet
as something separate from life itself
it's like it is life
because they never had that moment of
encountering it because they've lived in
that world since they were young so i
think there's no there's no doubt about
that that they're more screwed up than
we are
though it's a it's a pretty low bar
let's be honest well tomorrow is a
really exciting day for the daily wire
why because we'll be releasing our new
show the enemy within the docu-series
features acclaimed journalists and
expert in national threats lee smith who
uncovers just how far the ccp's
infiltration of america goes and a
political coup orchestrated by ruling
elites to generate their own wealth and
power at the expense of the american
people's safety and freedom from faulty
to our education system to hollywood and
everything in between each episode will
take you deep into what's going on
behind the scenes
what those who are supposed to be
protecting you don't want you to know
check out the trailer
what if everything we think we know
about our leaders
our society and our relations with the
rest of the world is wrong
america is facing two major challenges
one is the chinese communist party
however the most significant threat
comes from within as you're trying to
obscure responsibility for four million
people dying around the world senator
paul you do not know what you are
talking about
we've already seen evidence of how the
elites want to run the united states
they're modeling themselves after
chinese autocracy for over a decade the
people's republic of china
has stood publicly accused of acts of
cruelty
and wickedness
that matched the cruelty and wickedness
of medieval torturers and executioners
dianne feinstein
had a chinese spy as her driver for 20
years we're not talking about
one person infiltrating senior levels at
the cia or the white house we're talking
about an entire elite class throughout
the political corporate academic
cultural and media establishment my name
is lee smith i've been a journalist for
more than 30 years this is the most
astonishing espionage and infiltration
operation in history
what you're going to see in this series
will shock you
this
is the enemy within
[Music]
the enemy within will start streaming
this friday february 18th exclusively at
the daily wire so if you're not a member
now's the time to change that head to
dailywire.com subscribe to join us today
and also i can't stress this enough if
you haven't yet seen the daily wires new
film shut in you've got to change that
head to dailywire.com
subscribe to get a membership and start
streaming today it's streaming
exclusively for daily wire members and
it's very popular with the audience on
rotten tomatoes
both critics and general audience they
all love it so you got to go subscribe
we're creating more and more great
entertainment without a leftist agenda
and it's all thanks to our daily wire
members you guys make it possible
so head to dailywire.com subscribe today
so you can watch shut in and we've got a
lot more coming this summer hyperions
gina's new movies out the summer as well
so you're going to miss all that if
you're not a member dailywire.com
subscribe
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so i've mentioned before the campaign of
psychological warfare being waged
against me by my wife and children who
for years have been trying to coerce me
into funding and even accompanying them
on a trip to disney world
now we never went to disney world when i
was a kid our amusement park was a sheet
of plastic a grassy hill and a garden
hose homemade slip and slides never
worked like the store-bought version but
we made do
and we liked it too we didn't need no
dang fancy glorified carnival
we ran around outside all day without
our shoes on came home for supper supper
was a boiled raccoon in a rusty pot and
we liked that too and i would say mom
can i at least have some salt for the
raccoon and she would say boy you'll get
some salt from those tears when i whip
your behind
this is how i lived or at least it's the
version that i tell my kids all the time
and i've tried to explain all this to
them perhaps taking poetic license with
one or two details but they're not
convinced mostly because their mother is
working against me sabotaging me every
step of the way and the end result is
that now we will be going to disney
world because i can no longer withstand
the pressure
my only hope is to keep putting off the
trip using various stalling tactics at
least until our youngest is 25 or so
already i've successfully convinced my
wife that we uh we can't go this spring
for
whatever reason i came up with obviously
we don't want to go in the summer it's
getting too hot so instead let's shoot
for the fall and that gives me several
months to think of a reason why we can't
go in the fall either maybe i'll say
that we can't go because it's election
season and i have to stay here and uh
watch the polls or whatever
but as horrifying as disney world will
surely be
whenever i'm finally forced to actually
go
it's only the tip of the iceberg here's
the latest an article from the verge it
says disney has launched a new business
for fans who can't bear to leave the
pristine family-friendly world the
corporation has nurtured through its
theme parks and media ventures
story living by disney will operate as
part of the company's theme parks
division developing a series of
master-planned communities for
residential living designed by disney's
creative staff and offering the same
pampered tranquility found in its
resorts
one location has been announced so far a
community of 1900 housing units named
cotino that will be built in the city of
rancho mirage in california's coachella
valley concept art for katina shows
villas condos and housing complexes
clustered around a 24-acre grand oasis
which disney says will offer clear
turquoise water powered by the crystal
lagoons technology deployed at its
resorts amenities will include shopping
dining entertainment as well as a
beachfront hotel and clubhouse hosting
disney programming entertainment and
activities throughout the year
now this truly sounds like a fantastic
housing opportunity if you have so
despaired of your human existence that
you want to totally surrender yourself
to disney so that every aspect of your
life is subject to corporate programming
i mean even more than it already is
now if you think this sounds
horrifically dystopian like something
out of a black mirror episode wait until
you see the promotional video
i'm proud to announce our next disney
experience story living by disney all
new disney branded master-planned
residential communities designed to be
the perfect setting for disney fans to
write the next exciting chapter in their
lives and some neighborhoods will be
planned for residents ages 55 and over
story living by disney allows us to
leverage what we do best world-class
service legendary storytelling and
creativity
this exciting new venture will enhance
extend and strengthen the disney brand
by allowing us to bring the magic of
disney to places you may never have
expected
these vibrant communities will be
infused with disney place making
picture an energetic community with the
warmth and charm of a small town and the
beauty of a resort a place that entices
inspiration makes every moment more
memorable than the last a story living
by disney community is something truly
special
the charm of a small town except it's
owned by a company worth 200 billion
dollars now she says it's like a small
town but also like a resort
only a resort is a place where people
wait on you hand and foot and you're
subjected to so much unrelenting and
obtrusive comfort and luxury that it
quickly becomes exhausting in its own
special way meanwhile a small town and i
say this as someone who just moved from
one is a place where you can live
independently and do things yourself and
have some semblance of privacy and have
something of your own
and experience the bonds of community in
a non-facilitated organic non-forced
kind of way
so a small town is the exact opposite of
a resort and that is its whole charm
still even if the small town pitch is
silly
who wouldn't want to live in a community
dedicated to as we were told
enhancing the disney brand
these are surely the values we want to
pass on to our children when our
children ask us what it means to live in
a community and be a good neighbor we
can tell them that it means undying
fealty to a multinational corporate
brand and when our children ask us the
meaning of life we can tell them the
meaning of life is the brand
and when our children aren't satisfied
with that answer and begin to hunger for
a deeper and more authentic existence
we could tell them to come with us to
the disney doctor so he can give them
some special pills that will make all
those unpleasant ideas go away
you know i i find myself more and more
having to remind people that the truman
show was not meant to be an instruction
manual
it's supposed to be a nightmare not a
dream come true it's a it's a dystopia
not a utopia
but this is probably where we're headed
as a country i mean in 10 years we'll
all be living in disneyville or amazon
land or walmart walmart town
and the worst thing about it is that
most people probably won't be real
enough by that point to be bothered by
how unreal and curated their everyday
life has become
again we already live in an unreal
curated reality and many people are not
nearly as bothered by it as they ought
to be in fact they like it
as much as they can like anything given
that their passions have been dulled as
they more and more turn into faceless
robotic consumers
as for disney specifically
you know lots of adults these days cling
obsessively to
not their childhoods as a whole but
specifically the brands and
entertainment franchises of their
childhoods
they're still adults like they're adults
complaining about
and they get really upset
complaining about the new pixar films
and and how they're it's the animation
isn't as good as it was you know when
toy story first came out
or you know these these new disney
movies they're not as good as uh i don't
like them as much as when i was a kid
that's because they're for kids
and the disney movies you saw when you
were a kid you were a kid when you
watched them
that's why you don't like them as much
now
because it's time to move on with your
life
and develop tastes that are suitable for
an adult
but those are the only things that they
remember about their childhoods that's
why they cling on to it
it's how they define their past and also
their present and their future
and so there will be unfortunately a
vast population eager to go live in a
community totally dedicated to the
corporate entertainment that has always
defined their lives
and maybe it's for the best
you know get get all those people in one
place segregate them
and then carve out the whole plot of
land and eject it into the sun
that would be my plan anyway
and if we can't do that then at least we
can say to them that you're all canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
voldowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire on today's
episode the canadian government cuts off
funds to the freedom convoy democrats
are divided over defund the police and
the oscars bring back posts
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire